[Music]
so far as we've journeyed through the
micro cosmos the organisms we've shown
you are mostly aquatic you might find
them in oceans or rivers or lakes
finding their own niche in their watery
ecosystem and surrounding them dissolved
in the water is always oxygen which is
essential to their survival but as you
travel down and find where water meets
sediment a transition occurs yes from
more liquid to more solid but more
importantly the sediments impede the
movement of oxygen which means that as
oxygen gets consumed by living organisms
the concentration goes down the
transition here is in many ways even
more distinct than the transition from
the land to the sea in our macro world
yes it is difficult for fish to live out
of water and hard for us to live in it
but ultimately fish and humans are both
based on roughly the same metabolic
chemistry we both rely on oxygen but
here at this transition where the
environment goes from oxic meaning there
is oxygen to anoxic meaning there isn't
life's metabolic chemistry fundamentally
shifts its muddy they're slimy a little
smelly maybe even a little gross but too
many organisms the oxic anoxic
transition is a shifting chemical
boundary that has created a challenge
for life a challenge that changed its
nature a challenge it conquered so let's
talk about the organisms that prefer an
environment void of oxygen because many
of them will end up shaping the world
around the organisms that live along
this transition
now we're not quite sure but we believe
this long large tightly coiled bacterium
as a type of spirochete many of which
prefer to live without oxygen they come
up often in these mud samples and you
might know some of their kind as the
more familiar and less welcome organisms
that cause syphilis and Lyme disease and
just to note this video is not sped up
the organism really moves like this
spirochetes are uniquely motile able to
move around even in the thick viscous
substances to vastly oversimplify the
entire basis of our life as we know it
Oxygen's big important role is to accept
electrons and the chemical processes
that make our cells go and our existence
possible
so thanks oxygen but organisms that live
in anoxic environments substitute oxygen
with other chemicals some like this
ciliate sino Morpha are found in
environments rich in oxygens downstairs
neighbor on the periodic table sulphur
along with bacteria that thrive in a
sulphuric world now these look like
vibrating hyperactive worms but they're
actually bacteria specifically a purple
sulfur bacteria
these are thioester Ilham inside the
thioester Ilham our little globules
where they stock sulfur for later use
they're photosynthetic and they often
prefer anoxic environments these
bacteria use various forms of sulfur to
produce their energy including in the
case of thioester Ilham those sulfur
stores
[Music]
in these kinds of sulfuric sediments
you'll find concentrations of sulfur and
oxygen as opposing gradients as you
descend into sediment the concentration
of oxygen decreases consumed by the life
that depends on it
meanwhile sulphide diffuses upwards from
the anoxic microbes below and as you
travel further down the sulfur
concentration increases as you get
closer to its source
but in that sediment as a layer where
oxygen and sulfur coexist this is the
oxic anoxic interface a several hundred
micrometer thick boundary that attracts
bacteria like these a chromium oxalá
Ferrum a large sulfur bacteria found in
freshwater and salt marsh sediments that
comes up often in our mud samples
similar to thioester Ilham a chrome
adium has small sulfur globules but the
bacteria is also able to roll upwards
through the sediment in what seems to be
a response to the presence of oxygen
suggesting that it might take up oxygen
as well currents in the water and
various other changes in the environment
can affect where the oxic anoxic
interface is so a chrome Adium and other
bacteria that thrive in this layer need
the ability to sense and move in
response to the shifting oxygen and
sulfur layers these gradient roving a
chrome adium have so far been difficult
to grow in large quantities in a lab
perhaps because their natural
environment and the relationships they
have with their surrounding microbes are
just too complicated as a result these
bacteria remain mysterious giants their
bodies contain sizable stores of calcite
but we don't know what they're for some
scientists have guess
that they might help control the acidity
of the cell while others have suggested
it might help regulate the cells
buoyancy there are many theories
including that the amount of calcite
inside a chrome atom makes them
off-putting to predators now we don't
know if that's the case with this luck
so DS Magnus which is valiantly trying
and failing to eat this akram Adium we
did observe it for a while and it kept
rejecting the giant bacterium so at the
very least there seems to be something
on appetizing about them here with some
akram Adium is a fellow interphase
bacterial macro monus moving around with
the use of its flagella macro Mona's
seemed to also keep a sulphide stock in
little globules and are distinguished by
inclusions where they store calcium
oxalate which may help the cell keep up
its metabolism even when the conditions
around it aren't good you can see the
inclusions in this clip here the larger
those calcium oxalate stores are the
slower the bacteria moves there is of
course so much more to the story of mud
and microbes the oxidations and the
reductions the various forms of the
Sulphurs and the oxygens not to mention
the carbons and the nitrogen's that we
did not even mention it's messy and we
don't mean muddy we mean complicated as
you might have noticed oxygen is pretty
important to biochemical mechanisms we
can live weeks without food days without
water but only moments without oxygen
and metabolic systems on this planet
evolved largely in the presence of this
marvelous versatile and common electron
acceptor without it everything changes
every balance has to be reweighed 'add
every gradient shifted and yet
step back and look at these anoxic
environments everything seems to come
together in a muddy elegance one
gradient gives way to another one
process swaps out for another and the
micro cosmos distributes itself
accordingly
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us journey to the micro
cosmos is produced by complexly if you
want to keep imagining the world complex
me with us we have a bunch of other
things we're producing a crash course on
artificial intelligence right now hosted
by Jabril ash over 20 episodes we're
gonna unpack the logic behind AI systems
and even write and implement code in
labs check out the first video but the
history of artificial intelligence and
the revolution that is happening today
as a link in the description if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]